thấy file Word của mình rất là xấu và không có trình bày rất
là xấu và không có bố cục rõ ràng. Mình chỉ vất tất cả
những số liệu lên đây chứ Bây giờ mình sẽ nhờ AI của mình
để chỉnh sửa tạo một file mới sao cho đẹp và có bố cục
rõ ràng. Đây là file Word mới mà AI đã tạo cho mình.
nó đã có tất cả header và demo và các loại
hình, mốc trang, nó đã được format lại và chỉnh sửa
lại đẹp hơn rất là nhiều.
Chào các bạn, hôm nay mình sẽ chia sẻ cách tăng hiệu suất làm
việc văn phòng lên gấp 10 lần mà không mất phí và cần kiến
thức gì về AI. Qua về mình, mình là kỹ sư phần mềm cấp
cao và mình cũng là người quản lý và điều phối các báo cáo,
cuộc họp, hoạt động của team. Tất cả công việc văn phòng của mình
đã được mình tự động hóa. Hôm nay mình sẽ chia sẻ về Antigravity,
công cụ mới ra mắt của Google cuối năm ngoái, là phần mềm ai
cũng nên có. Nếu bạn từng dùng qua AI một lần thì bạn cần
Anti-Gravity. Đơn giản, Anti-Gravity là một nơi mà AI có thể
truy cập vào, tạo và quản lý tất cả mọi thứ trên folder của
bạn. Nếu bạn thấy hay, hãy chia sẻ với mọi người.
Nhớ đăng Like, Subscribe để mình có thêm động lực làm những video tiếp
theo. Let's install Antigravity.
Đây là page chính thức của Antigravity Google.
Bạn chỉ cần lên Google search Antigravity là ra.
Bây giờ mình sẽ tải Antigravity.
Và mình gặp phần Download. Cho Mac thì bạn sẽ download phần mềm này.
Và cho Windows mình sẽ download x64. Và
mình đã tải Antigravity rồi. Được bây giờ mình sẽ mở và cài đặt
Antigravity. Đây là phần
mềm Antigravity sau khi được tải,
và mình sẽ mở và cài đặt nó. Accept the agreement.
Next. Yes. Next,
create a desktop icon. Next,
install Antigravity.
OK, Anti-Gravity của mình đã được setup thành công.
Bây giờ mình sẽ mở lên và cài đặt nó. Ok,
Welcome to Antigravity. Mình sẽ Next,
và mình Start Fresh. Và mình chọn Line Model.
Và mình chọn AI Driven Development.
Và mình Next. Bây giờ mình phải sign in với Google account của
mình. Let's sign in. Ok,
bây giờ mình đã sign in thành công và mình mở lại Antigravity.
Hẹn gặp lại bạn trong tiếp theo nhé! Next,
OK. Bây giờ mình sẽ mở folder của mình và mình muốn làm
việc cùng với Antigravity. Bây giờ mình sẽ mở folder document của mình.
Ở trên folder document này mình đã có một file Word để chuẩn
bị demo cho video ngày hôm nay.
Đây là file Word của mình. Mình đã tải file Word Extension.
nếu bạn không mở được file Word thì bạn hãy vào Extension và
chọn Office, Office Viewer đây.
Và bạn tải Office Viewer này và bạn sẽ có thể mở được tất
cả những file của Office như Excel,
Word, PDF và mọi thứ.
Quay trở lại, mình sẽ,
Đây là file Word của mình. Bạn có thể thấy file Word của mình
rất là xấu và không có trình bày rất là xấu và không có
bố cục rõ ràng. Mình chỉ vất tất cả những số liệu lên đây
chứ mình không làm tất cả những edit và chỉnh sửa gì.
Bây giờ mình sẽ nhờ AI của mình để chỉnh sửa tạo một file
mới sao cho đẹp và có bố cục rõ ràng.
Bây giờ mình sẽ mở Sonnet 4.6 và mình sẽ vào tạo một AI
từ file Word này với bố cục làm đẹp.
và làm cho phần trình bày đẹp hơn để xem con AI của mình
có làm được không nha tạo một file mới từ file
Word đây từ file Word này và
bắt đầu để nó chạy Ok,
con Gemini của mình đã tạo thành công một file mới.
Bây giờ để xem xem nó đã làm những gì nha. Bây giờ nó
đã đọc nội dung của file document này của mình và tạo một file
mới, những thay đổi về thiết kế màu sắc,
phông chữ, tiêu đề, Heading và Hyperlink,
bảng biểu, dấu trang và bullet. và Highlight.
Ok, để mình sẽ mở xem cái file mới,
xem nó thay đổi như thế nào. Bây giờ mình sẽ mở Document và
tìm file mới của mình là Demo Formatic.
Đây là Demo Formatic, new file Word mà nó đã mới tạo cho mình.
Đây là file Word mới mà AI đã tạo cho mình.
nó đã có tất cả header và demo và các loại
hình, mốc trang, nó đã được format lại và chỉnh sửa
lại đẹp hơn rất là nhiều. Đó,
đó là Anti-Gravity. Nếu bạn thấy hay,
hãy like, subscribe để